[Music]
this morning on the dish a culinary whiz
kid who's already making his mark born
and raised in South Florida
Jeremy Solomon started cooking at age
seven knew he wanted to become a chef by
age nine and at 13 started his own
cooking blog to connect with other
like-minded teens he came to New York to
attend the prestigious Culinary
Institute of America
got jobs at top restaurants and then at
just 24 was named executive chef of the
Eddy in New York's East Village
showcasing food specialties from his
family's Hungarian heritage he's now
earned a second Executive Chef position
at Wallflower featuring French regional
cuisine chef Jeremy Solomon good morning
welcome to the dish we are in love with
this table yeah it's here so can I start
with dessert I mean so this is Sacher
Torte it's a traditional Austrian tour
it might also my grandmother Aggies
favorite it's filled with apricot jam
and finished with a chocolate ganache
over here we have stuffed cabbage
whoever it's a vegetarian stuffed
cabbage so it contains pecans and rice
it's for you
pickled raisins we have a bee tartare so
kind of a take on a beef tartare if you
will finish it some horseradish and
chopped egg pork schnitzel which is the
highlight of this table which is just
breadcrumbs egg flour very traditional
served with some lemon and Down Yonder
is our radicchio salad with Tokai
poached pears mmm I would have to say
this this little number here oh yeah
this is by far the star of the table
yeah Cheers
this is our Tokai cobbler finish with a
little bit of dry sherry oh my gosh
that's that is really good yeah first of
all I have to say when you told your mom
if the age of nine that mind you that
you wanted to be a chef was she
receptive to that idea
she you know the day before that I
wanted to be an actor and so I was
making a commitment that day so yeah she
she took it pretty wicked pretty well
she was like okay great let's let's do
this so what was the first real
cooking job for you then my first real
cooking job was at a country club
actually my grandparents Country Club
grandmother got to the job right nan
Arlene like the chef to let me peel
potatoes so I started when I was 11 and
I would go after school peel potatoes
and then I graduated to scooping sorbet
into martini glasses literally work in
the freezer yeah they would hand me a
freezer jacket and for about an hour and
I had like a few minute break in between
and I put on music and scoop sorbet were
you drawn to Hungarian cooking at your
grandmother's background when we drawn
to it then or did that come later that
came much later I was always intrigued
by grandma geese cooking but it wasn't
until I was about 1617 that I started to
take an interest in my heritage did she
do a hard sell on her was she kind of
mysterious about it very mysterious
about it she didn't really want to
revisit her past so but it kind of came
out in her cooking so it'd be a bowl of
goulash next to a wedge salad with
Russian dressing or a Thousand Island
dressing or a steak next to a schnitzel
so it was always you know very American
very Hungarian your history in terms of
just the eddy alone you started as a
line cook and four years later you were
the top chef yeah which is pretty crazy
now that you're telling me I know I
really haven't know as time flies by and
you don't really think about it but yeah
I started as a line cook and became a
sous-chef tried escaping I went to go
travel for a bit and then I got a call
to come back when you would you say when
you travel that was when you got some of
this Hungarian cooking though right yeah
I went to go visit my family in Budapest
I haven't I hadn't seen them in a very
long time so I went to about two months
I stayed with them also travelled to
Austria and then went to Paris just for
saying I went to Paris right but yeah it
was it was pretty incredible it was
nothing that I you know you have this
idea that when you go to Europe you're
gonna have this like fantasy eat Pray
Love experience right and it was just
totally nothing that I had imagined it
was even better at the any you you were
actually serving some of your
grandmother's
peas correct yeah we're actually both my
grandmother's so there's a little bit of
like a Jewish influence and I'm
Hungarian influence so we're doing a
schnitzel makes it onto the menu or Ron
tutush as you would call it a Nigerian
stuffed cabbage although it's not a pork
stuffed cabbage it is a it's my version
of it I love that you said that you you
you want to preserve your grandmother's
Hungary mm-hmm there's not a lot of
there's not many Hungarians like my
grandmother left and I want to preserve
her cooking but in a new way and that's
the best way to do it kind of introduce
it to everyone and as you are we
introduced the dish to you and you sign
it who would you have this meal I would
have this meal with my Hungarian
grandfather who unfortunately passed
away when I was much younger so he's the
only immediate family member that I
never had the opportunity to cook for
probably would want to share this with
him oh that's wonderful
well chef Jeremy we so appreciate you
being here and thank you
and I always like to show the dish Matt
Mayes that's a nice one very much it is
and for more on Chef Jeremy and the dish
head to our website at
cBS This Morning Calm